[Musique]
j'ai acheté la place que j'ai sur ce
tournage je peux pas risquer de tout
perdre c'est impossible comme une idée
qu aller je veux pas vous dire ton
on est quelque chose que je vous ai pas
dit il en couple avec la réalisatrice du
film
vous voyez que vous veniez son tournage
moi j'arrive plus à réfléchir je n'ai
plus à me projeter non c'est impossible
sa blessure castle et pionnier audace
pousser de petites histoires
[Musique]
sanchez
toi y'a des gens fêtent leur vie sont
très malheureux et il n'arrive jamais à
guérir du malheur du coup ils sont
obligés de prendre plein de trucs pour
billets qui sont et qui pâtit le reste
de l'énergie la consacre essentiellement
à pourrir la vie des autres tu apprennes
à manipuler tamer plus ça te servira
pour plus tard parce que tu sais tu
cumules de choses avec elle à cette
amère et les psys
maman tu pars de pargesa pour y arriver
dans la vie je posais qui sont vraiment
étrange %
sam jazz
aujourd'hui les gens ils sont saturés
d'information ils ont plein plein de
raisons de ne pas lire donc en fait ça
jamais été aussi illégitime qu
aujourd'hui peut-être de publier un
livre dont je dis pas ça pour te pour te
décourager ce tract est peut-être parti
au plus mauvais moment quand il m'a dit
ah disons que tu arrêtais que tu voulais
devenir si tu me dis que tu vas t'y
remettre que tu fais le vide autour de
toi et c'est super c'est super sauf
qu'on sait très bien que l'inspiration
toi comme moi ça n'existe pas et on sait
aussi que le travail ça sert à rien
taddei simoni qui l'a qui va sortir un
livre là je crois sur le affaire
d'hommes de meurtre par texto si une
meuf t'a envoyé des centaines de textos
un ami elle suicidaire jusqu'à ce qu'il
passe à l'acte
ça c'est un bolide de femmes